collect your credits and enjoy a
delicious kawaki and monkey lizard
delicious because the highly-anticipated
mandalorian is here it's awesome and
thinks story is here to break it all
down great you're gonna want to stick
around for the entire video because
we'll be going over that twist ending
and the impact it could mean for the
season and for the Star Wars universe on
an unknown ice planet we get our first
glimpse of the Mandalorian it's
approximately five years after the
events of Return of the Jedi after the
fall of the Empire but before the
emergence of the first order the galaxy
is in disarray with several power
vacuums having formed which will find
various characters including Verna
Hertzog's the client making moves the
life for bounty hunters has also taken a
turn for the worse when the Mandalorian
visits grief carga the bounties pay
barely enough to cover his gas but we'll
get to that in a bit the Mandalorian
holds on to a tracking fob leading him
to a local Cantina where his target a
mythril is being harassed by some local
trawlers basically they're this planet's
version of tough-guy fishermen even
saying that they could sell his glands
for a good price at the port and he does
look like some sort of shape of water
creature the language they're speaking
is Huttese which likely means the planet
is Hutt controlled the Mandalorian
enters and is immediately accosted by
these men and budget Karl Urban over
here asked him if his armor is made from
real best car steel best car steel also
known as Mandalorian iron is an
extremely durable and rare steel only
found on the planet Mandalore and it's
moon
Concordia I also just want to say I'm
loving the use of practical makeup here
they could have made mithril CGI but he
looks so much better and lifelike with
the practical effects it hasn't even
been two minutes in the Mandalorian
kicks the crap out of the thugs even
cutting one in half at the blast door
he's here to collect the bounty on this
mithril not to save his life the first
episode of the series sets up our
protagonists character arc he's a
ruthless bounty hunter who only cares
about money but with that twist at the
end I'm sure his major internal dilemma
this season we'll see if he changes to
put people in honor before a few extra
credits it's kind of like Han Solo's arc
from a new hope in which he only cares
about cash
but later risked his own life to help
Luke in the rebels look I ain't in this
for your revolution and I'm not in it
for you princess I expect to be well
paid I'm in it for the money we get a
glimpse of what's known as a bounty puck
which displays a hologram of its target
essentially this Star Wars version of a
wanted poster as well as confirmation
that the Mandalorian does indeed speak
however no statements have been released
on whether he will take off his helmet
although of this trailer is any
indication it may be a possibility the
Mandalorian takes mithril and cuffs to a
kuba Zion ferryman the Kubas species and
their homeworld of qu bhindi were
enslaved by the Empire during its reign
a droid operated vehicle comes to take
them to the yards but the Mandalorian
requests a non droid hinting of the
Mandalorians distrust of them droids can
be programmed and tracked and in a world
where deception seems to be at an
all-time high the Mandalorian takes
certain precautions the driver uses
binoculars similar to those used by Luke
and a new hope to keep an eye out for
Ravin acts an amphibious ice dwelling
creature with a penchant for ships we
also get a look at the Mandalorian ship
the razor crest essentially a pre empire
military craft that has been retrofitted
for the Mandalorian the poor driver is
eaten by a Ravan AK when the Mandalorian
and his bounty make their escape the
Mandalorian having to prod the creature
with a weapon hardcore Star Wars fans
might recognize from the Christmas
special an ambien phase pulse blaster
mythril tries to find out how much the
Mandalorian is getting paid in the hopes
of upping the ante he says he has a lot
of credits but the Mandalorian remains
unresponsive mythril excuses himself to
go to the washroom explaining it may
take a bit longer because he is molting
also known as shedding he also mentions
that he had hoped to be free for life
day we all remember life day don't we
[Music]
we get this cool shot of the
Mandalorians weapons cache filled with
all sorts of blasters and gadgets but
mithril snooping gets him a quick trip
to the Carbonite chamber the same
substance was used in Empire Strikes
Back to freeze Han Solo the Mandalorian
has captured three other bounties and is
on his way to collect with grief carga
on another planet
grief is according to Wikipedia the head
of the bounty hunters guild of which the
Mandalorian is a member he turns in his
for trackers but scoffs at grief paying
him in imperial credits after all the
Empire is no more taking an exchange
have to pay for calamari flan we haven't
seen calamari flan before but I think
it's safe to say it's the currency of
the Mon Calamari species this is just a
quick little shot I really liked of the
bounties being unloaded it's not
necessary for the story but really gives
a flavor of the Star Wars world and
that's one of the things I loved about
this first episode how it will show a
shots of the Mandalorian travelling
through the streets or linger on images
of the extra to really give us a sense
of the planets were visiting grief tells
the Mandalorian of a special job perhaps
underworld in nature no bounty puck or
chain code for this one it's a direct
Commission but pays high he's given a
chit which allows him access to the
clients hideout a chit which is scanned
by this droid just like the one from
Return of the Jedi were taken to a
character portrayed by Verna Hertzog who
is only known as the client because his
identity is hidden I wouldn't be
surprised if his character has a big
reveal later in the season or if he's
connected to a bigger Star Wars
character we already know there are a
few things to note here
particularly the dirty stormtroopers in
the Imperial insignias on the client's
outfit suggesting he may have been a
higher up in the Imperial Army before it
collapsed and these are his men who have
stuck by his side were also introduced
to dr. Pershing who holds the tracker
fob for their special bounty Pershing in
the client had previously made a deal
that the bounty be delivered alive but
the client goes back on this telling the
Mandalorian it's acceptable for it to be
brought back dead but for a lower fee
not much is given to the Mandalorian
just the fob and the bounties age 50 we
learn a bit more about how bounties work
was something called a chain code the
last four digits of which tell the age
so the
chain code is luckily a string of code
which tells discernible characteristics
and information about these bounties in
return for the assets retrieval the
mandalorian will receive a cam Tohno of
best car that prized Mandalorian or or
which the client believes belongs back
to its rightful people the Mandalorians
you might be asking ourselves what is a
cam tow know the word actually
originates from a viral video in which a
young girl can't pronounce the word ice
cream I love ice cream in Empire Strikes
Back a man fleeing Cloud City carries a
white barrel with electronic switches on
top which was actually a converted
ice-cream machine thus creator jon
favreau decided to take the word cam
tono to mean a safe in the Star Wars
universe when we visit the armorer who
later forges a pauldron for the
mandalorian we learned best car steal
was stolen from the Mandalorian people
during the Great Purge the Great Purge
is likely referring to the great Jedi
purge in which Palpatine created the
Galactic Empire and eradicated the Jedi
Order directly above the armorsmith is
this symbol a mythos or Skull mythos
ores were enormous creatures native to
Mandalore and were driven to extinction
by the Mandalorians their skulls later
becoming this symbol of the Mandalore
the traditional ruler of the Mandalorian
people there's a brief mention of them
later on during the blerg taming seen
when the ugh not queal portrayed by nick
nolte
tells him his people used to be able to
tame the mythos ores
the armor also asks him if his signet
has been revealed now we don't really
know what this means but cygnets are
generally used to signify being a member
of a group or organization and seeing as
he's already a member of the guild and
were given these flashbacks of him as an
orphan here it could have something to
do with his Mandalorian heritage a
heritage which judging by his more
upscale robes leads me to believe he
came from either royalty or the upper
class regardless the armor said the
signet will soon be revealed the
Mandalorian gets a sweet new best car
pauldron and makes his way to a desert
planet in search of this high paying
bounty searching the arid landscape he's
attacked by creatures known as blergh
and we even get to see him using his
flamethrower van braces these
flamethrowers were often used by man
lorian's has anti Jedi weapons since the
flames could not be blocked by their
lightsabers lucky for our hero he's
saved bike wheel of the ugh not race I'm
not sure if I'm saying his name right
since his name is actually never said in
the episode so bear with me these shock
darts seem to incapacitate the blerg and
the Mandalorian has taken two quills
outpost where he learns his destination
isn't traversable without the help of a
blergh so he has to tame one after a
less-than-ideal start taming one queal
and the Mandalorian make their way to
the bandit outpost where the asset is
being held will even rejects the money
offered to him for his service saying
the real payment will be the removal of
these thugs off his planet ever since
they arrived there's been nothing but
trouble the Mandalorian is forced to
attack when a bounty droid IG 11 voiced
by takeaway TT arrives he too is also in
search of this valuable asset as the two
are slowly surrounded by enemies the
Mandalorian suggests they work together
and split the reward - which IG 11
agrees his character provides some
much-needed comedic relief during this
very tense moment offering to
self-destruct multiple times during the
battle also he's just plain badass
providing covering fire for the
Mandalorian so he can use his grappling
hook gadget and commandeer this huge-ass
blaster which makes quick work of the
remaining enemies now here is where
things get interesting
inside the hideout is the asset a small
yoda-like creature orphaned just like
the Mandalorian was the name of Yoda's
race has never actually been revealed
but the actors on the show have referred
to him as the being we know this species
ages slower than our own with its
current age of 50 pegging his creation
around the time of Anakin Skywalker it's
likely this creature is not Yoda's own
offspring as Yoda often taught of the
dangers of getting too emotionally
attached to people just like how Anakin
became romantically attached to Padme
another possibility is that the being is
related to Y Adil who served on the Jedi
High Council during the fall of the
Galactic Republic her exploits are
recounted in the book Star Wars Jedi
Quest where her character is killed
while on a mission with obi-wan Kenobi
and Anakin Skywalker however the book is
considered non canon there's also the
question of why the client wants this
asset on
dr. Pershing who wants it alive likely
to observe it and perform tests on it
the client doesn't care if it lives just
like IG 11 whose mission was to
terminate it the being is likely
extremely for sensitive making it a
valuable ally or enemy depending on the
person does this mean all these people
the Mandalorian killed were mercenaries
smugglers or perhaps former rebels we'll
have to see how things progress there's
also this cute little et moment where
they put their fingers together with the
beings crib floating in the air whether
that floating is done by the crib or
from the beings force powers we simply
do not know but I like to think it's the
latter hinting that even as a small
being it's extremely powerful the
Mandalorian shoots IG 11 preferring to
keep the child alive whoever
commissioned that droid will likely be
hot on their tails I hope you enjoyed
this first Mandalorian break down smash
that like button and comment below your
thoughts and theories for the season and
make sure to subscribe because I plan on
covering the entire show you can also
follow me on Twitter at Kings story YT
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much